the artist and the fundamentalist arise
from societies at differing stages of
development the artist is the advanced
model his culture possesses affluence
stability enough excessive resource to
permit the luxury of self-examination
the artist is grounded in freedom
he is not afraid of it he is lucky he
was born in the right place he has a
core of self-confidence of hope for the
future
he believes in progress and evolution
his faith is that humankind is advancing
however haltingly and imperfectly toward
a better world the fundamentalist
entertains no such notion in his view
humanity has fallen from a higher state
the truth is not out there awaiting
revelation it has already been revealed
the Word of God has been spoken and
recorded by his prophet bahid Jesus
Muhammad or Karl Marx fundamentalism is
the philosophy of the powerless the
conquered the displaced and the
dispossessed its spawning ground is the
wreckage of political and military
defeat as Hebrew fundamentalism arose
during the Babylonian captivity as white
Christian fundamentalism appeared in the
American South during Reconstruction as
the notion of the master race evolved in
Germany following World War one in such
desperate times the vanquished race
would perish without a doctrine that
restored hope and pride Islamic
fundamentalism has sends from the same
landscape of despair and possesses the
same tremendous and potent appeal what
exactly is this despair it is the
despair of freedom the dislocation and
emasculation experienced by the
individual cut free from the familiar
and comforting structures of the tribe
and the clan a village in the family it
is the state of modern life the
fundamentalist or more accurately the
beleaguered individual who comes to
embrace fundamentalism cannot stand
freedom he cannot find his way into the
future so he retreat
to the past he returns in imagination to
the glory days of his race and seeks to
reconstitute both them and himself in
their pure more virtuous light he gets
back to basics to fundamentals
fundamentalism and art are mutually
exclusive there is no such thing as
fundamentalist art this does not mean
that the fundamentalist is not creative
rather his creativity is inverted he
creates destruction even the structures
he builds his schools and networks of
organization are dedicated to
annihilation of his enemies and of
himself but the fundamentalist reserves
his greatest creativity for the
fashioning of Satan the image of his foe
in opposition to which he defines and
gives meaning to his own life like the
artist the fundamentalist experiences
resistance he experiences it as
temptation to sin resistance to the
fundamentalist is the call of the evil
one seeking to seduce him from his
virtue the fundamentalist is consumed
with Satan whom he loves as he loves
death is it coincidence that the suicide
bombers of the World Trade Center
frequented strip clubs during their
training or that they conceived of their
reward as a squadron of virgin brides
and the license to ravish them in the
fleshpots of heaven the fundamentalist
hates and fears women because he sees
them as vessels of Satan temptresses
like Delilah who seduced Samson from his
power to combat the call of sin that is
resistance the fundamentalist plunges
either into action or into the study of
sacred texts he loses himself in these
much as the artist does in the process
of creation the difference is that while
the one looks forward hoping to create a
better world the other looks backward
seeking to return to a purer world from
which he and all have fallen the
humanist believes that humankind
as individuals is called upon to
co-create the world with God this is why
he values human life so highly in his
view things do progress life does evolve
each individual has value at least
potentially in advancing this cause the
fundamentalist cannot conceive of this
in his society dissent is not just crime
but apostasy in his heresy transgression
against God Himself when fundamentalism
wins the world enters a Dark Age